Speaker 1: Let's go next to Telvin
from Indianapolis. Telvin, welcome.
Telvin from Indianapolis. Welcome.
Speaker 2: By David Campbell.
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: All right. Sorry if I become too clear
the first time. I'll keep it real brief. Had just
a quick response question. The second deeper dove
question. Sure. Responds with the Washington Post
posting last night that Donald Trump is officially
under investigation. Do you really think anything
is going to come of that? Is it really just
investigating his cronies and circle around him?
And second question, knowing how good the right
seems to be at charging its base and getting the
locals interested in government things since our.
Basically since the last politicians thing. Excuse
me. Democrats have no teeth when it comes to
getting. Anyone on the local level charge.
Wouldn't you think it might be up to or good
ideas for platforms and for lack of a better
idea, like you're the Young Turks, like, hey,
we're going to expand out to local stories or try
different ways to get different individual states
more charged in your local base, such as things
that you're saying, Hey, you could lobby for
important races that you brought up earlier, for
lack of a better word, like memorize that race.
Speaker 1: I completely agree with you that that
would be a great thing to do. The difficulty is
for a national show where only, you know, I my
guess would be no more than 1% of our audience
is actually eligible to vote in any of the state
particular state elections. Right. Like how much
of our audience votes in Pennsylvania is it? 1%.
I don't know how much of our audience votes in,
you know, Matt Gates district in Florida. It's got
to be it's a fraction of 1%. So the difficulty is,
are we better off talking about ways for people to
get involved locally so that they do it wherever
is local to them, rather than spending time in one
specific local race that very few of our viewers
might actually even be eligible to vote in and
possibly alienate people who are like, That's not
interesting. That has nothing to do with with my
day to day. So this is a this is a challenge for
national shows. And I don't know what the answer
is, but I understand your motivation for asking
about about the local focus.
Speaker 2:
All right, thanks. And once again, to
that first question, just to get response,
do you really think anything major is going
to affect, you know, the OJ fans, captain,
or that really probably just his cronies?
Speaker 1: I don't want to deflate anybody, but
I still if you just give me an even
odds, bet this Trump get indicted. I
still say no. I'm closer to yes than I've
ever been. But I'm still on no Telvin.
Speaker 2: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Unfortunately, I kind of felt
the same way because the report says Trump is
under investigation, but he doesn't specifically
say he's indicted or anything. Well, no.
Speaker 1: It wouldn't say that the indictment
would come later. But I know what you're saying.
I'm not particularly optimistic. All right. My
friend Kelvin from Indianapolis, thank you so
much for the call. Very, very much. Appreciate it.